Der Demokratische US-Senator Dick Durbin hat
am Freitag in Chicago Vorwürfe gegen Präsident
Donald Trump bestätigt.
Der soll bei einem Treffen im Weißen Haus
Zitat "vulgäre" Sprache genutzt und afrikanische
Länder und auch Haiti wiederholt als "Shithole
countries", zu deutsch "Drecksloch-Länder"
bezeichnet haben.
Nach eigener Aussage hatte Durbin selbst bei
der Zusammenkunft über die Auswirkungen von
bestimmten Regierungsplänen auf Migranten
berichtet.
Vor Durbins Bestätigung hatten mehrere Insider
berichtet, Trump habe folgenden Satz gesagt:
" Warum wollen wir diese Leute aus Afrika
hier haben?
Das sind Drecksloch-Länder...
Wir sollten mehr Leute aus Norwegen haben."
Trump selbst hatte sich am Freitag über den
Kurznachrichtendienst Twitter zu Wort gemeldet.
Niemals habe er etwas Herabwürdigendes über
Haiti oder Haitianer gesagt.
Das, so Trump, sei eine Erfindung der Demokraten.
Reporter-Nachfragen nach seinen Kommentaren
und einer möglichen Entschuldigung schien
Trump am Freitag im Weißen Haus zu überhören.
In Haiti, aber auch hier in Nigeria haben
Trumps angebliche Äußerungen für Entsetzen
gesorgt.
Auf den Straßen von Lagos zeigten sich Bewohner
am Freitag getroffen.
"Dass Trump so etwas über afrikanische Länder
sagt, ist wirklich, wirklich, sehr böse und
ich denke, dass jedes afrikanische Land etwas
daraus lernen sollte.
Bleibt in Euren Ländern und arbeitet mit
dem, was ihr dort vorfindet.
Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass dann alles besser
wird."
"Das kommt ja nicht ganz unerwartet von jemandem,
dessen Natur wir nun schon kennen.
Ich denke, dass ist eine Bemerkung, die nur
jemand wie er machen kann.
Wir als Afrikaner sollten uns auf uns selbst
besinnen."
Auch die Vereinten Nationen äußerten sich
empört.
Das seien schockierende und beschämende Kommentare
des US-Präsidenten.
Man können nicht anders, als sie als rassistisch
zu bezeichnen, so Rupert Colville, UN-Sprecher
für Menschenrechte.